well now I have to fight this guy
because he I don't even like this girl
really so now it's like a but it's a
it's a weird thing so I just pretended I
didn't hear him oh my go
that was it was kind of like scuffle
then I was like that was that she's like
did you hear what he said I was like no
you have to fight for my honor yeah yeah
I hated girls like that are you getting
your head snapped like I'm gonna get a
hot dog well I've had I've had girls
that I've dated that would not want they
would just ladies if any ladies listen
to the show all three or four ladies
that are listening to the show right now
if just don't get your man into a fight
let him decide don't start talking shit
to another dude you're putting him in a
situation that maybe he does want to be
in and you're never gonna know whether
or not he wants to be in that situation
you're never gonna get the honest story
what's going on his fucking mine right
there just know we never want you to
start talking shit to a dude in the
middle of an altercation because it's
never gonna end good no most of the time
most of time does not end good
especially if blows start flying man
people getting knocked out some guy got
hurt really bad at a Dodgers game
recently he got knocked out and cracked
his head off the ground that's what
people need to understand people die
from that shit you watch movies and
people knock people out and the person's
fine you know you could get a goddamn
murder rap if you punch someone and they
fall and most people when you punch him
in the face that go unconscious they
have no idea what happened they go
unconscious their head bounces off the
ground they die it happens all the time
Kevin James when he was a kid when he
was a bouncer in Long Island and one of
the guys at the bar I don't think he was
working that night but one of the guys
he knew and worked with knocked guy out
the guy fell hit his head off a curb
dead guy went up to go in jail for years
spent years in jail at some fucking $10
an hour job where you fighting drunks
yeah just getting into some dumb fight
which is thinking it's okay to just tee
off on someone's face it's also probably
pretty rare people falling and hitting
their head and dying that's not rare at
all that's really common think about
what that is somebody I've seen a lot of
people get knocked out so absolutely you
gotta ask like I'm saying dying from
hitting their head in the car I haven't
seen him die but they could easily yeah
if you I mean I guarantee you in a major
city like New York I bet somebody dies
falling and hitting their head
the curb every week when you punch
someone and they fall think about how
far that is right think about the amount
of force that's involved now think about
if you were standing there and someone
hit you in the back of the head with
something now think about that something
was the fucking world the earth it
doesn't give at all concrete doesn't
give it all the only thing that gives
your head your head has to bounce and
your skull fractures and you get
internal bleeding your brain hemorrhages
it cuts off your ability to move you
might have a stroke you might have an I
mean it's horrible getting knocked out
and falling and hitting your head off
the ground is a terrifying thing and
when you hear the sound of smack of
someone's head bouncing off the concrete
it's it's tear it sounds hollow it
sounds like like a like a melon it
sounds terrible like a hard melon or
something yeah I yeah you see it
happened where people pass out there's
like videos that are out there if I
could fall over and then they just split
their head up it's like the worst dude
gruesome following backwards though
something especially when you get hit
you get fucking clipped on the chin your
head snaps and your lights shut off and
you just fall and bounce it's even in
boxing matches man so the scariest
knockouts when a guy gets ko'd and then
his head bounces off the ground yeah an
MMA in the OC same thing when guys fall
back and her head bounces off the ground
it's like a double knock so I watched
that fight science thing back in the day
they were doing on Spike TV I was like a
show called I think was called fight
science and they were just explaining
why
ground-and-pound was so much more brutal
than a straight up standing punch and
they were just good they like you know
they showed the 3d animation of the head
and the fist coming down and then the
head bouncing off the mat and then the
brain bouncing off the front then
bouncing to the back and the fist comes
back up again and your brain just being
over and over again and you can't go
anywhere you're stuck it's terrifying
all right I got beat up in the 6th grade
by an African kid named Babatunde look
at this every day 153 people the United
States died from injuries that include
traumatic brain injury what a minute
okay that include traumatic brain injury
so it's an injury that also has
traumatic brain injury yeah that's just
a head injury I see what they're saying
those who survive a TBI can face effects
that last a few days or the rest of
their lives
that's the other thing impaired thinking
or ma'am
movement sensation vision emotional
functioning personality changes or
depression these issues not only affect
individuals can have lasting effects on
families and community yeah um yeah man
don't don't get hit in the head avoid it
yeah take it for somebody that's been
hit in the head avoid it yeah I uh
whenever with my son cuz there's just
like a lotta there's a weird thing in
New York as well where there's like a
lot of tough guys that it's like this
alpha energy will get on the subway and
there's another dude who like make eye
contact with you and you're like weirdly
like you're in a weird beef now because
you're just looking at a dude in the
eyes yeah and it's and that and then it
becomes a thing where you have to like
look away right then you're in you have
this internal struggle we're going like
well no I don't I'm not gonna look away
because this guy's looking at me and
then and then I look at my kids right
there and I'm gonna like what is even
going on in my head right now I need to
just go to another subway car just avoid
at all costs having to get into a
confrontation in front of him because
that's one of my biggest fears in the
world is not knowing what to do there's
people that live in like Montana that
are listening to this right now they're
like what the fuck are you talking about
like you look each other in the eye and
some wants to fight there are no reason
this is the nature of being penned up
yeah that many people also fucking some
just something cool about it the cool
thing we talked about before that people
are like you are exposed even if you're
a poor kid you're supposed to rich
people they're there they're normal
it doesn't seem unattainable or unusable
they're all around you that path is
there well there are humans that are
there just like you you're around them
but if you live in a place where you're
never around them you never get that so
there's benefits to New York for sure
culturally there's benefits the just the
just the energy the city and so much
creativity is so much going on yeah